This problem seems really simple. But this
division sign is what's really interesting
about the problem. Dividing by a number is
actually the same as multiplying by the
reciporical. The reciporical of the number
is 1 divided by that number. So, for
example, the reciporical of 3 would be 1
3rd. The reciporical of a fraction, a over
b. Is b over a. This was actually true for
the number 3. We can rewrite 3 as 3
divided by 1, since that's still 3. And
notice the reciprocal of 3 divided by 1 is
1 divided by 3 or 1 3rd So the reciprocal
of negative 5 4ths would be negative 4
5ths And the reciprocal of 1 7th would be
7 over 1 or just positive 7. Now what we
know that a reciprocal is let's go back to
this division. We said dividing by a
number is the same as multiplying by its
reciprocal. So I can change 4 divided 2
into 4 times 1 half. So if I do 1 half
times 4, I know I should get 2. Whether we
know it or not we actually multiply by
fractions right here 4 is the same as 4
divided by 1 and I got a result of two.
We're going to look more closely at this
throughout the rest of the lesson.